bonsoir david alors est les occidentaux
au prix de première sanction réaction la
reconnaissance des républiques
autoproclamées quelles sont-elles ces
sanctions mais bon soir olivier des
sanctions qui en maintenant une fois
était répétée des menaces de sanction
qu'on m'a tellement de fois été répétée
elles sont désormais effective est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'elles sont plus
ou moins mesuré par rapport à ce qui
avait été annoncé dans le détail l'union
européenne a acté hier le gel des avoirs
des 351 députés de la douma au sein même
de l'union européenne
elle s'est même 351 députés qui ont voté
pour l'indépendance des deux républiques
autoproclamées ils sont également
interdits de visas est sur le sol de
l'union européenne est les 27 ont
également décidé d' entraver la capacité
de la russie à accéder aux marchés de
capitaux et aux services financiers
européens en particulier pour refinancer
sa dette elle prévoit aussi est des
interdictions d'importation des produits
à deux en provenance des régions de
dounia ce qu est l ouganda la plus
grosse sanction en tout cas c'est comme
ça qu'elle est qualifiée par là
plusieurs médias c'est celle en
provenance de berlin puisque elle a gelé
le gigantesque projet du gazoduc north
stream 2 qui était censé acheminer
davantage de gaz russe en allemagne est
la france par l'intermédiaire de jean
yves le drian le ministre des affaires
est l'étrangère et puis par la voix de
son porte parole et gabriel attal s'est
félicité de la rapidité d'exécution de
ces sanctions écoutez
ces sanctions envoient un message clair
et sans ambiguïté à la russie elle
réaffirmerons notre soutien à l'ukraine
à sa souveraineté à l'heure où la russie
va jusqu'à nier son existence elles sont
aussi je veux le dire un premier paquet
de sanctions et d'autres pourraient
suivre notre vigilance reste totale et
la coordination entre alliés maximale
nous restons bien sûr prêt au dialogue
nous restons prêts à tout tenté pour
éviter une escalade fatal aux
conséquences potentiellement très grave
sur la sécurité internationale nous ne
reculerons devant aucun effort ni aucune
sanction pour en dissuader la russie car
cette course en avant d'un nationalisme
russe qui retrouve ses rêves dans pire
menace les principes même de l'existence
de notre europe des propos assez fort en
vous l'avez entendu un de la part de
gabriel attal et puis ces sanctions
peuvent être évolutive elles peuvent
être graduelle bruno le maire a le
ministre de l'économie a lui aussi
insisté sur le fait que des sanctions
infiniment plus pénalisante aux intérêts
du peuple russe et de l'économie russe
pourrait être appliquée alors la ville
comment réagit la russie après ces
sanctions alors ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que des voix russes ont jugé ces mesures
modestes par rapport à ce qui avait été
préparé par rapport à ce qui avait été
annoncé puis surtout la russie s'est
préparé à ces sanctions le pays a
accumulé près de 640 milliards de
dollars dans ses réserves de change
c'est-à-dire des avoirs en devises
étrangères et en or un détenu par la
banque centrale russe et 183 milliards
en fonds souverain pour y faire face
malgré ça vous l'avait dit en début de
journal dans le créneau a promis une
riposte douloureuse est forte acs
sanctions revient un communiqué elle
publié par le ministère des affaires
étrangères russe cette riposte elle vise
surtout celles annoncées par les états
unis et par joe biden indirectement
moscou a insisté également sur le fait
que la russie reste ouverte au dialogue
et à la diplomatie une réponse indirecte
à l'annulation des rencontres entre
sergueï lavrov et anthony blinken qui
devait être avoir lieu ce jeudi et celle
prévue avec jean yves le drian un
vendredi à paris alors en ce qui
concerne ces rencontres ça devrait se
décanter d'ici la semaine prochaine
puisque vous le savez chaque camp
espèrent trouver une issue diplomatique
à cette crise merci beaucoup david pour
toutes ces précisions vous